somehow feels like uh  yeah it's it's a very very bad yeah done  to one second again vladislav is an  expert i mean he's an expert playing  on one second  i don't know how he does this but he's  constantly doing it yeah look d7 i mean  how do you find the square that you are  not losing the is the same idea  basically yeah i can have done to one  second again  in the last second playing rook d1 but  quincy had basically forced the win on  the on the spot  but okay black is just completely  winning now  king fc runs into queen h5 check  so no way to defend like this  and and okay now the pieces are running  out of squares  running out of squares all of black's  pieces are on the dark squares and i  think this is the point where our tamiya  yes indeed he does resign and with that  ding clearance cause